[Music]
on this thursday night
sidelining sports to fight for racial
justice
it's amazing why we keep loving this
country
and this country does not love us back
the new game plan for pro
athletes demanding change hurricane
laura
roars ashore i'm just glad that we are
all alive the homes and lives turned
upside down
in louisiana and hyper high-speed
connection
i'm excited about it the potential rapid
ride between edmonton and calgary
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
there are so many storms happening
tonight political
racial and when that is actually related
to weather
division and inequality are in the
spotlight and major league sports are
taking a stand
supporting the black lives matter
movement which is front and center again
on sunday a police officer in wisconsin
shot jacob blake in the back
multiple times and that has led to
violent protests
the american president donald trump is
vowing to restore law
and order but blames the unrest on
political rival
joe biden and local democratic officials
and
all of this is happening as a
catastrophic hurricane battered the u.s
gulf coast
and there's still the pandemic that has
killed 180 000 americans
and in no way is it under control we'll
break everything down for you
but we begin tonight with the athletes
becoming activists
eric sorenson has our top story after
the nba
rocked the sports world by going dark
the reverberations have now shaken
sports in this country
the nhl calling off thursday's playoff
games
the league held a moment of pregame
reflection wednesday over racial
injustice
but many believed it fell short of what
the moment called for
i don't think we should be here i think
the nhl should postpone the games
i really feel that we should be more
supportive of black lives matter
the jarring halt in sports came from the
nba
in its bubble players were willing to be
isolated from covet 19
but refused to be walled off from
society's latest confrontation over race
and police brutality the milwaukee bucks
their city just down the road from
kenosha
where jacob blake was gunned down by
police from behind
said basketball must halt despite the
overwhelming plea for change there has
been no action
so our focus today cannot be on
basketball others followed suit
the toronto raptors had been among the
first to express frustration
playing games at a time like this what
are we willing to give up do we actually
give
about what's going on fred van vliet
in particular has always been a powerful
voice eric karine a reporter with the
raptors says the team was a major force
for action
bringing buses into the bubble
emblazoned with black lives matter
one of the most stark images of the
early days of the nba bubble
it's become to them like their voices
and just speaking out aren't enough it's
time for action
this is a human question now it's
humanity
do we value all lives or do we only
value some lives
the nba is perhaps the largest
collective of mostly black
influential athletes in the world but
they did not want their product
to mask the divided culture that
insulates much of america
from the injustices black people endure
it's amazing
why we keep loving this country and this
country
does not love is back the wnba also
kneeled down
and spoke up just because we are a
basketball player doesn't mean that's
our only platform we need to understand
that
when most of us go home we still are
black there was solidarity from other
sports
some major league baseball games
canceled nfl teams walked out of
practice
a tennis star postponed her match
reminiscent of
individual acts of courage for racial
justice in the past
but this is bigger the largest most
widespread day of sports activism
that our country has ever seen if not
now when
current and former nba-ers released from
play-by-play
spoke from the heart i know people get
tired of hearing me say it but we are
scared as black people
in america by getting off the court nba
players turn the spotlight onto
america's undercurrent of racism
that society too often ignores or worse
denies eric sorenson global news
and protesters are back on the streets
of kenosha tonight demanding justice for
jacob lake
last night's demonstration was much
calmer than the chaos scene early this
week and today city officials called on
the community
to keep protests peaceful
the law enforcement the national guard
the sheriff's department all of them
they're here to be protective and to
help
protect the community and to also keep
protesters who are
peaceful protesters safe
local law enforcement refused today to
provide more information about the
shooting and what prompted officer
rustin chesky to open fire on blake
instead they're planning to answer
questions at a news conference tomorrow
chesky and the other officers involved
have been placed on administrative leave
civil rights activist reverend jesse
jackson was in wisconsin today demanding
an unbiased investigation
into the shooting the investigation
should be
in the two who watched it they should be
indicted as well
because if jacob had shot the police
seven times
wouldn't be if he'd get killed he
couldn't have gone home tonight come on
sir
we need police but not above the law all
this drama
unfolding in the u.s is happening under
the leadership of president donald trump
by the way his response to the
basketball boycott
people are tired of the nba trump is
expected to paint a rosy picture of
america at the final night of the
republican national convention
our washington bureau chief jackson
proskow is following those developments
jackson
that speech is coming from the white
house how rare is that and
what do we know about the focus of the
president's speech
good evening robin before we get to that
we should point out that a crowd of
several thousand people has started to
build outside the white house in protest
to tonight's speech and the crowd is
growing as we get closer to that hour
inside the white house compound on the
south lawn about
1500 trump supporters are sitting
shoulder to shoulder and you're right
it's highly unusual
to have this type of overtly political
speech come from the white house grounds
we should also point out there are no
masks or social distancing required on
the premises
the speech itself is expected to attack
joe biden heavily
in one release expert excerpt the
president says he has spent the last
four years
cleaning up from joe biden's many
decades in power
we should also point out though that
trump faces specific criticism for not
laying out what the next
four years under him might look like he
hasn't laid out a specific vision
and it's not clear that he's actually
going to do that tonight in fact much of
the republican convention this week
has faced heavy criticism for really
glossing over the details
of the everyday situations that
americans are facing right now the
pandemic record unemployment
and of course the protests that are
gripping major cities in this country
that's simply not the reality
that's being presented this week robin
what about the democrats what are they
doing to counter trump's message
well this is politics and they are
counter programming kamala harris gave a
speech today in which she excoriated
president trump
over his handling of the kovit 19
pandemic she said
he was frightened and scared and hid in
the worst moments
and joe biden has bought ads on all
major tv networks tonight to air just
before donald trump's speech
we should also point out that just today
more than 100
former republicans officials in the
government officials who've worked for
previous republican presidential
campaigns
they came together and said they will
not only endorse joe biden
they will actively work to get him
elected jackson brosko in washington
thanks jackson
the u.s is also dealing with a monster
storm that's leaving a trail of death
and destruction in its wake at least
four people were killed in one state
laura has weakened to a tropical storm
but it roared onto the louisiana
shoreline overnight as one of the most
powerful storms ever to hit the u.s
the category 4 hurricane packed winds up
to 240 kilometers an hour
it tore off roofs knocked down trees and
cut power to hundreds of thousands of
residents
mike armstrong reports
hurricane laura slammed ashore making
landfall in western louisiana around
1am and look at that it was packing a
punch
heavy rain and strong winds this was
shot by a storm chaser just after the
eye of the hurricane passed
definitely some sort of mezzo board has
either just slammed me
laura hit land with sustained winds of
more than 160 kilometers an hour
gusts were even stronger at least two
national weather service radar stations
were knocked offline one was destroyed
they're built to withstand winds up to
215
kilometers an hour this weather network
reporter had a close call
showered with glass being torn off a
building
we're fine with everyone we are fine
in the darkness it was hard to evaluate
the damage
in the daylight it was obvious this is
what we're seeing you see some down
power lines
some downed trees as well laura left a
wide trail of destruction as it headed
north
the flooding was actually less severe
than predicted but those winds
were not some areas were devastated
though the governor of texas says his
state made out better than expected
considering the size and strength of the
hurricane we did dodge a bullet
now that of course doesn't help those
whose homes have been hit we got a
little bit lucky it was very big it was
very powerful but it passed quickly
president trump says they'll visit the
region over the weekend but for now the
focus on the ground is on opening up
roads and restoring power
mandatory evacuation orders are being
lifted though some people weren't able
to get out
before the storm hit i got bumped in the
head and i'm trying to like
get back home that's it yeah it's been a
rough morning it has
and you know i'm just glad that we are
all alive that's it
now there are shelters for people who
can't make it home but authorities
aren't using gyms or convention centers
due to concerns over covet 19. people
are being given hotel rooms instead
another concern is a fire in west lake
louisiana a canadian-owned chemical
plant is sending up
dangerous smoke people in the area are
being told not to go
outside mike armstrong global news
nbc's chris pallone is on the ground in
lafayette tonight chris what's the scene
like there after such an incredibly
powerful storm
robin i think the most remarkable thing
is is that the
most intense part of this storm probably
blew through this part
of the state 14 hours ago and we haven't
seen rain in several hours the sun is
trying to peek through
but we are still getting really strong
wind gusts here sometimes
even sustained winds that are pretty
high just goes to show that
as this storm right now is well on its
way into arkansas and points northward
that it's just so large we're still in
the back half of it
uh 14 hours later is there a sense that
life can return to normal soon mind you
under a pandemic yeah it's a bad well
normal is relative right uh so we're
still in the pandemic
but um in parts of the state absolutely
it's really remarkable this is the most
powerful hurricane ever to hit the state
of louisiana
and if you listen to the governors of
texas and louisiana both of them seem to
make it sound like
it could have been much worse where this
storm struck
mostly focused on louisiana there are
certainly
very very damaged parts of the state to
be sure there will be
millions if not billions of dollars
worth of damage
there's a lot of power out 800 000
people
texas louisiana and arkansas now mostly
here in louisiana it will take days if
not weeks in some places to get that
power back on
but you certainly do feel a palpable
sense of
you know this could have been worse
chris pallone in louisiana thanks chris
in new zealand the white supremacist who
murdered 51 worshipers at two mosques
was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole
survivors and victims families
celebrated as they heard the news
the judge imposed the maximum available
sentence on the 29-year-old gunman from
australia
it's the first time it's ever been used
in that country the march 2019 attacks
targeting muslims at two separate
mosques were live-streamed by the gunman
on facebook
the massacre prompted changes to global
social media protocols
new zealand also tightened its gun laws
canada's foreign affairs minister met
with lebanon's president in beirut today
francois philippe champagne confirmed
canada is willing to commit the rcmp to
help an
independent investigation of the port
explosion that devastate the capital
but he says it must be credible
transparent and thorough
we're more than happy to contribute
we've done that as you know in the
special tribunal for lebanon
but it needs to be done under conditions
that will be
our assistance will give faith to the
lebanese people
that this is an investigation that will
go to the bottom of things
champagne toured a world food program
distribution center and had a first-hand
look at the city's
decimated port the catastrophic
explosion that ripped through beirut on
august 4th killed nearly 200 people
and left thousands homeless so far 19
people
most of them port and customs officials
have been arrested
it's been hit after hit for alberta
coming up the dire economic forecast for
wild rose country
alberta released its fiscal update today
and the forecast is dire
the double blow of collapsing oil prices
and the kovid 19 crisis
have pushed the province to the brink
alberta is facing its largest ever
deficit and soaring
unemployment heather yorks west reports
casey johnson was a young father when he
started a small
oil field business in 2010. there's
always an emotional component
you know to um you know to business you
know i'm really close you know with my
kids and you know with my family and uh
i always uh you know when they were
little you know we started the company
and they just
you know loved hanging out with dad and
his uh
you know in his big trucks last week his
two oldest boys posed for one
final picture that was a really hard
decision to make um you know to pull
you know the company off you know life
support after a number of difficult
years in the energy sector 2020 began
with a promise for recovery but then
everything changed
in march alberta encountered what i
would
characterize as a triple black swan
event the global economic contraction a
collapse in the price of oil and the
covet 19 pandemic
have been devastating to alberta's
economy it's projecting the largest
deficit the province has
ever seen 24.2 billion dollars this year
of more than 16 billion from february's
forecast
revenue has fallen more than 11 billion
unemployment is projected to hit an
average 11.6 percent in 2020
a more than 30-year high as the forecast
shows alberta's economy shrinking by
more than 8 percent
the government has warned a fiscal
reckoning is ahead
listen stay tuned for budget 2021 again
we believe at a time like this it's
absolutely essential
that alberta delivers the most efficient
services possible but no sales tax not
yet
instead the province wants to attract
new investment to help with recovery
never count alberta out but after 20
years in oil and gas
johnson admits right now for his family
he's just not sure what's next
heather urex west global news calgary
the saskatchewan government is
projecting a slightly lower deficit than
initially feared
the province is now forecasting a 2.1
billion deficit for this fiscal year
which is down from june's projection
of 2.4 billion scotland's government
says it expects to run deficits for the
next three years before squeezing out a
125 million dollar surplus
in 2024-25 and like alberta the
saskatchewan government says
it isn't projecting any tax increases
still ahead quebec's
to school plan put to the test
you're watching global national
[Music]
quebec's controversial back-to-school
plan is being put to the test
tens of thousands of french language
students return to class today
each class will be a separate bubble and
masks are required in common areas for
kids in grades 5 and up
the government has faced criticism from
groups who say the plan
doesn't go far enough meanwhile three
employees at three different montreal
schools have tested positive for covet
19.
the school board says they were not in
contact with students
authorities in france are imposing
strict new measures to try to head off a
new wave of covet 19.
face masks are now mandatory across
paris infections are surging in the
capital and among young people
france reported more than 5 400 new
coveted 19 cases on wednesday
a level of infections not seen since the
height of the epidemic in april
india has reported over 75 000 new
infections in the past
24 hours it's a single day record and
accounts for nearly
half of the new cases reported worldwide
in that same period
india recorded more than a thousand new
fatalities the government in new delhi
is pledging to double its daily tests
to 40 000 a day retail giant walmart has
confirmed it's teaming up with microsoft
in a bid for tick tock
the parent company of the popular video
app is reportedly close to an agreement
to sell its canadian
u.s australian and new zealand
operations
sources say it has not yet chosen a
buyer but a deal could be announced in
the coming days
tick tock was pushed to look for a buyer
after the u.s threatened to ban the app
calling it a security threat the
company's ceo kevin meyer
resigned today saying his decision comes
after the political environment
sharply changed high speed hopes up next
the futuristic design for a rapid
transit line
in one province
it's been nearly 60 years since the
cartoon family from the future
introduced the world to a transit dream
traveling by tube
jetson style could be a reality in
alberta a toronto team is pitching to
build a high-speed hyperloop between
edmonton and calgary
sarah mcdonald looks at who's on board
and who isn't
we're designing a spacecraft that's
constructed like
an airplane and operates like a train
it's futuristic transport technology
that's
within reach according to the company
working to bring it to canada
it's an aircraft without wings so of
course there's technical details and
and and challenges to address but
overall it's it's
using existing technology toronto-based
transport
has been given the green light to study
the feasibility of hyperloops in alberta
it will kind of provide a much faster
service a system that would transport
people and cargo
in tubes between edmonton and calgary at
speeds of up to a thousand kilometers
per hour
i'm excited about it i don't know if
it's real i don't know if it's science
fiction but we'll never know
unless we continue to do more testing
municipal and provincial officials
publicly supporting the prospect of the
privately financed multi-billion dollar
endeavor
there's no cost to the taxpayer and
we're not
in the business of writing blank checks
for
as yet unproven technology but transport
canada
has concerns that technology isn't yet
fully conceptualized
a report released wednesday casts doubt
on the viability and affordability
of it the consulting firm commissioned
last year to conduct its own study
calls the technology potentially too
pricey and too unproven
to be a realistic form of transport
pinning the estimated cost for
development and technology
at more than twice the price proposed by
transpond
there's many missing holes and
information
still transport plans to move forward
with its own study
with the support of alberta's
transportation ministry with early
feedback
expected by next spring the company
optimistic construction could begin
as early as 2025 sarah mcdonald global
news vancouver
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the sunset in
lockport manitoba
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you